way three and then we once again have  bishop with a check  yes  it is  i think it's uh the only way to go  knight d5  hikaru taking almost half a second to  play it yes  not in the move to waste time  takes on a3 knight f4  does not look  thrilled he will  capture on e5  he's in such areas dropping the pieces  like knight g6  you want to pre-move  it and today it's a short day  for candidate standards yeah that's  just five hours  uh  yeah  nearly  yet  carl accepts a draw although is a piece  up  yeah so we had another very interesting  uh day of round three of the candidates  even though we had four draws  but still there were a lot of action  especially  in the game of alireza's game and in  dingley run against rockport  we will have two guys who are very  disappointed going into this rest they  know ding lyrin not winning a winning  position  against rapport and staying on -1 and  alireza when he finally got white and  put pressure